ach du scheiße was hatten jahren
gestellt hey ich sehe aus wie so ein
schwiegermutters liebling so etwas
gedacht jetzt willkommen beim video ja
meine haare sind gerade noch nass
das hat nix also die werde ich noch
machen auf jeden fall haben gesagt
freitag und ich brauche noch tolle
sachen weil ich habe hier in köln bekam
fast die hälfte zu hause vergessen
ich brauch wegen eines bestimmten anlass
und noch ein schönes outfit deswegen
hoffe ich auch mal es wird schön auf
jeden fall zumal wie auch hier passiert
ist ich mache jetzt erst einmal
nachhaltig kurz los geht ja da ist
eigentlich überhaupt keinen bock auf
shoppen habe ich mir gedacht ich gehe da
nicht shoppen sondern liege für mich
stoppen auf jeden fall werde ich jetzt
gleich 100 euro geben ich finde mit 100
euro kann man schon einiges anfangen und
man kann auf jeden fall was nettes
zusammenstellen hoffe ich mal also wir
leben hier wirklich von thun hose und
pulli und jacke und keine ahnung jaja
500 euro das alles wenn die haben ich
sitzen aber natürlich immer hier ist auf
jeden fall wenn ich mal gespannt und ich
setzte sich dabei ab und du kannst das
aussuchen oder dann bräuchte ich ja und
dann hab ich mal das ist ein schönes
outfit der das wäre echt krass wenn das
so richtig geil mit dem chic sichersten
noch los dann kaufe ich gar nicht
also leute jetzt noch in größe noch so
alles klar sagt wir sind noch nie so
leute machen das kann ja nur noch besser
werden als das hier ist wie du die
kamera so haben wir sehen was ich noch
so finde keine noch besser werden
das hier so leute ich muss jetzt hier in
irgend so ein dreck parkhaus fahren auf
jeden fall gebe ich dir jetzt 100 euro
kaufte davon ja keine schminke so leute
hier sind 25 server scheine das ist 100
euro leute ehrlich zugeben
sechseinhalb stunden später
ja
wie teuer also hast es nicht geschafft
ja aber was ist wenn mein volk
runtergesetzt drücke ich bin erstaunt
ich bin von mir ich muss erstmal
schlafen so leute herzlich willkommen in
meinem zimmer
ich hoffe du hast wirklich was tolles
gekauft weil sonst gibt's ärger das
waren 100 euro und ich habe wirklich
hohe erwartungen gehabt
wir haben hier wir müssen uns zu sagen
eigentlich hab jetzt auch extra was
gekauft heute abend auch ein event sind
und alex hier leider keine schönen
klammer doch schon also wir haben ja
einmal fahren aber da ist auch noch
sachen von herrn ändern was habe ich mir
jetzt alles eine hose ein t shirt eine
mittelschule und politisch minus zehn
grad gefühlt und kantig hat das system
angeboten
[Musik]
mehr mitte 50 noch nie mit damit hier
gesehen muss ich nicht und sie haben wir
haben bis sie eine anzughose fast das
lustige war auch ich habe mir gar nicht
gesagt welche größe ich habe und so was
ist musste ich alles so was wir drauf
haben und jetzt bin ich war gespannt als
wenn du für 100 euro und dann noch diese
sachen und welt bekommen hatten bisher
waren 39 30
hat irgendwer von euch schon mal wenn
ich für 69 euro gesehen
wow ich sind voll geil 240 jahren
halbmast venture ist ja so 214 halb 43
oder zwei jahr 42 halb ist eigentlich
nur das passende 143 darf man so alle
jungs haben sich zwischen zwei und platz
voll okay
und jetzt bin ich echt mal gespannt ob
das im kombinierten gut auf die ihr
könnt jetzt mal in die kommentare
schreiben
ich glaub ihr sie hat was gutes gekauft
oder glaubt ihr sie hat total verkommen
aber ich denke eigentlich dass könnte
echt cool werden also das wird schon mal
kurz auf die andere kam nach diesen
catwalk ach so nein doch also wir fangen
wir an wir mit das teilt 99 90
ich mache das macht ihr das auch immer
so einfach gut was macht die oberen
knöpfe sieht sie auf ja nein oder so
weil sonst sich das so ich weiß nicht
ich bin jetzt echt mal gespannt ob mir
diese hose steht aber krempelte so ein
bisschen um die schon dessen besser wenn
ein nur an einer seite die das ist ja
echt ist die enge treiben
aber es gilt ich bin dass du deinen
willst du mich auf einen
aber ich bin schon längst ranzen
das sieht jetzt gut aus was wird
sozusagen von 0 bis 10 39 also ist jetzt
nicht perfekt aber ganz gut aber ich
sehe richtig auslesen
ich glaube dass dort so eine brille dann
werde ich so ein richtiger möchtegern
hipster oder hey ich bin doch gar nicht
schlecht
ich finde es nur mit den socken hat ein
bisschen blöd oder dem schlag und dann
hast du so einen blöden schwarzen socken
housemarque also kannst meine socken
anziehen guck mal ich guck mal was er
jetzt auch trendy es ist das wenn leute
dann einfach so was sowieso machen was
mich immer nicht trennen
die show die sind echt mega wenn die gut
aus wenn jetzt im schnürsenkel vergessen
haben er ist hier drin
machen wir den schnürsenkel richtig
ach du scheiße was hat sie mit mir
angestellt
hey ich sehe aus wie so ein
schwiegermutters liebling so leute
gefühlte zwei jahre später und jetzt
dazu solche mit absätzen
das macht gar keinen sinn die borussia
ist für so wenn es 20 grad draußen ist
das t shirt auch sogar noch wärmer und
eine mütze heute bei 10.000 12.000 icx
kauf ich mache mein outfit und dann
dieses mal was ich modisch alles drauf
hat
echte auszügen spanier also ich muss
sagen jetzt mal firma immer von oben
nach unten
es war eine ernste erste frage so kannst
du viel heraus gehen arbeiten mit seinem
rüden reden was genau ich fühle mich
sowieso einer der songs um seiltanzen
können
denn seit 1 ich finde dir steht die
mütze auf jeden fall viel besser als mir
also ehrlich sein ich hätte das was du
kaufst total anders eingeschätzt also
ich dachte kommt schon wirklich ganz
andere sachen wie das immer dann mal
kurz sein müsse jetzt einmal
dann kurz und dann werden wir das mal
gut in den kommentaren
eigentlich hatte ich ja was ganz anderes
zu kaufen aber irgendwie ich weiß nicht
warum es dann auf so was klar ist wenn
ich das jetzt so sehr so geht so ich
finde die hose cool aber ich glaube ich
würde die mit einem kurzen und oberteil
kombinieren leute bewertet man das oft
in den kommentaren von 0 bis 10 und
andere socken um socken passen gar nicht
aber wenn ich es gut finde das ist auf
jeden fall mandanten
vielleicht kann ich auch für marie man
auch kaufen jetzt habe ich wenigstens
ein schickes outfit und kann beruhigt
heute abend dahin gehen vielen dank
ansonsten den musikern wieder
ich habe mir bei instagram bei uns
vorbei ist eingebildet und wir sehen uns
dann dienstag wieder